ces billets vous les connaissez et
pourtant vous êtes de moins en moins
nombreux à les utiliser si la crise
sanitaire y est pour beaucoup le net
recul du nombre de distributeurs en
france s'explique par plusieurs raisons
alors que certains français doivent déjà
faire plusieurs kilomètres pour retirer
de l'argent la désertification bancaire
inquiète de plus en plus dans ces
conditions les distributeurs de billets
sont ils voués à disparaître
et doit-on s'attendre à la fin de
l'argent liquide
[Musique]
vous réglez comment cette question vous
est forcément familière en 2019 vous
étiez 59% à privilégier les espèces
contre 35% par carte mais la tendance a
évolué depuis un constat qui peut être
liée au nombre d'automates puisque
d'après la banque de france 56,6 % des
communes ne disposent d'aucun accès à un
distributeur de billets en france
métropolitaine on comptait 48 mille dab
ou distributeurs automatiques de billets
en 2020 soit une baisse de 3,2 pour cent
par rapport à 2019 bien que leur nombre
diminue chaque année une part importante
de français restent attachés à l'argent
liquide moyens de paiement des français
contrairement à ce qu'on peut penser
c'est pas la carte bleue c'est bien les
espèces pour tout ce qui est transaction
entre français d'une part et
transactions en magasin d'autre part
c'est quelque chose qu'ils savent qu'ils
se voient dans les enquêtes de la banque
de france et dans les enquêtes de
baisser notamment prête ici paiement sur
dix en 2019 était fait avec des espèces
et seulement une partie minoritaire avec
la carte bleue avec d'autres moins mais
alors pourquoi il est aussi attaché on
ne peut considérer que les français sont
attachés elle en est quitte pour
plusieurs raisons d'abord il ya eu
effectivement un côté tradition parce
qu'on paye avec de l'argent liquide
parce que nos parents ont payé avec de
l'argent liquide il ya aussi un côté où
l'argent liquide rassure les français
dans la mesure
c'est quelque chose de tangible on peut
garder notamment dans les périodes de
crise ce qui nous rassure parce qu'on
sait qu'on a cet argent à portée de main
ou on a l'idée que la banque peut
s'effondrer ou quel système peut
s'effondrer depuis plusieurs années les
habitudes des français évoluent selon
une autre enquête conduite par la bce en
juillet 2020 la population française
délaisse peu à peu l'argent liquide au
profit de la carte pour les achats
quotidiens une tendance vous est à la
fois par la crise sanitaire et le
développement du sans contact il ya une
tendance générale avec l'acceptation
générale
généralisée par les commerces de la cara
le coc vide a fini de convaincre les
commerçants qui ne voulait qu'il ne
voulait pas accepter les paiements par
cartes pour des raisons pratiques pour
des raisons financières aussi puisque
saab représente un coût faciale le
paiement par carte vous devez louer un
terminal de paiement vous payer une
commission à chaque transaction alors
que traditionnellement les paiements en
espèces a priori ont un coût neutre
alors qu'en fait il ya un coût le
relèvement du plafond de paiement par
carte bancaire
booster tout ce qui était paiements en
carte bleue parce que c'était plus
simple parce qu'on pouvait aller jusqu'à
50 euros est ce qu il a pu renforcer une
nouvelle fois l'attrait pour la carte
bleue c'est quelque chose de vraiment
nouveau
enfin c'est un c'est un phénomène
assez surprenant dans le sens où ça se
voyait pas jusqu'ici ce côté privilégié
la carte bleue sur les espèces les
chiffres parlent d'eux mêmes en 2020 les
paiements sans contact ont explosé avec
une augmentation de 53% tandis que les
retraits en espèces ou chuté de 23%
cette tendance a en partie contribué au
recul du nombre d'automates d'après la
banque de france si le nombre de
distributeurs baisse cette baisse se
fait toutefois sans une dégradation de
l'accès aux espèces en effet elle
précise que plus de 99% de la population
métropolitaine âgées de 15 ans et plus
résident soit dans une commune équipée
d'au moins qu'un automate soit dans une
commune située à moins de 15 minutes en
voiture de la commune la plus proche si
l'accès aux distributeurs et plutôt à
assurer un autre détail entre en jeu
certains consommateurs doivent parfois
faire plusieurs kilomètres pour trouver
un pour deux retraits compatible avec
leur banque pour pallier ce problème
entre autres certains dab n'écarte pas
l'idée de se mutualiser ce projet il à
l'état de réflexion de ce qu'on comprend
de ce que je vois moins tout cas il ya
un côté ou pour la banque l'intérêt
c'est de mutualiser les coûts
ce qu'un distributeur on l'a dit ça
coûte cher à entretenir notamment pour
faire venir l'argent pour s'assurer
qu'ils aient pas de problème qui
fonctionne bien c'est de la maintenance
donc pour la banque ça peut être une
économie ça permet aussi de renforcer le
maillage territorial en s'assurant qu'il
ya bien des distributeurs un peu partout
en fonction du degré de mutualisation
vous entraîne pas de commissions
d'interchange que les banques se paye
entre elles pour lé retrait déplacé mais
clairement du point de vue des banques
c'est une réduction des charges sur ce
point la france ne fait pas figure
d'exception puisque la belgique a déjà
sauté le pas en 2020 quatre grandes
banques ont créé la société bateau pan
chargée d'exploiter en commun les trois
quarts du parc de distributeurs belges
mais pour retirer de l'argent il
n'existe pas que les dab il est
désormais possible de retirer des
espèces chez certains buralistes un
système qui existe déjà chez nos voisins
britanniques un avantage d'une part pour
les territoires pauvres en automates et
d'autre part pour les buralistes qui
peuvent diversifier leurs activités
notamment pour pallier à la baisse de la
vente de tabac
[Musique]